[Music]  demi lovato continues to prove she is  all about body confidence  check out these steamy pics she's  rocking those bathing suits  Demi also shared this shot on the sand  of just her legs writing I don't have a  thigh gap and I'm still beautiful the  way I am a hashtag recovery a hashtag  self-love a hashtag everybody is  beautiful  twenty-four-year-old is one of our faves  on Instagram for being such a self-love  role model I'm excited  she shares tons of photos of herself  makeup free alike this one showing off  those adorable freckles and videos  galore of her rigorous workouts and time  in the boxing ring plus she's so not a  fan of Photoshop she posted this behind  the scenes shot from her 2016 allure  spread quote posting a no Photoshop pic  because I'm proud to show my body the  way it naturally is and yeah Demi's not  afraid to show a little skin either like  these topless and from the back photos I  love beating my boy  [Music]